hi I'm Evan Carmichael and welcome to
another edition of modeling the masters
I believe that the fastest and most
effective way to grow your business is
the model de strategies of people who've
already done what you're trying to do so
today we're going to look at how a young
entrepreneur had to choose between
starting a fashion business and served
in a supermarket business
he chose the fashion business and went
on to create one of the most
recognizable names in his industry this
is a story of Calvin Klein and the top
three lessons that you can learn from
his success Calvin Klein is an American
fashion designer and founder of the
company that bears his name as a young
child instead of playing sports like the
other kids
Klein spent his time indoors teaching
himself how to sketch and sew designs he
didn't have many friends and would often
accompany his mother on shopping trips
throughout the city on her quest for
discount clothing after graduating from
the Fashion Institute of Technology in
New York Klein was practically broke
still working part-time at his father's
grocery store and decided he would take
his two thousand dollars life savings
and start his own business he started by
designing a line of coats the company's
first major step to success came by
accident a year after its inception when
a businessman got off the elevator on
the wrong floor and happened to wander
in the Klein's office this businessman
turned out to be a coupe wire from the
major department store at Bonwit teller
after placing an order for $50,000 worth
of coats
he told Klein tomorrow you will be
discovered in his first year the company
booked one million dollars worth of
business in 2002 Klein sold his company
for four hundred million dollars and
thirty million dollars in stock before
the sale Calvin Klein had nine hundred
employees and worldwide sales of over
three billion dollars
by focusing on one who is passionate
about Calvin Klein was able to build one
of the most recognizable brands in his
industry to help you turn your passion
into dollars
here are three action items that you can
learn from Calvin Klein action item
number one be the expert if you're going
to have success in creating and selling
your product or service you better be
really good at what you do take classes
sign up for internships volunteer your
time take jobs and get as much hands-on
experience as you can to learn about
your industry before you start your
business the more you know going in
about how your industry works the
greater your chances of success will be
in order to succeed client exposed
himself to as much informal and formal
training as possible whether it was
sewing lessons from his grandmother
shopping trips with his mother or an
apprenticeship with the esteemed coat
manufacturer dan Milstein in the new
york fashion district Klein knew that if
he was going to succeed in the fashion
business he was going to have to take
advantage of every single learning
opportunity that presented itself the
Milstein apprenticeship only paid $75 a
week but a gave Kline firsthand
experience in the fashion industry which
proved to be invaluable
according to Kline I learned a lot
because he threw me into the snake pit
it's a fiercely competitive business and
Millstein was a perfect example of that
world people have done it without having
formal training in design but I don't
hire people unless they've been formally
trained I look for people who are really
talented creative inventive modern and
thinking and hard working because we're
in a very hard tough business action at
a number to reach a wide audience you
never know where your next customer is
going to come from and you don't want to
make the mistake of picking such a small
niche market that you won't be able to
make enough money to stay in business
make sure the market you're choosing is
big enough for you to create a
profitable company now and has room for
growth into the future Kline rose to the
top of the fashion industry by creating
products and advertising campaigns that
appeal to the broadest cross segment of
the population by not limiting himself
to a certain market and creating a wide
range
product lines accommodate all segments
of society Klein helped solidify his
position at the top of the American
fashion industry the key to his success
was his attempt to attract customers
from all walks of life
the ultimate attempt that brought in his
appeal came with the launch of the
fragrance line CK 1 the first unisex
perfume ever created by allowing anyone
to wear the same scent Klein broke down
all the barriers between his customers
client understood that if his business
was going to sustain a significant
market and had the kind of staying power
he wanted he had to create as broad an
appeal as possible
according to Klein fashion is about
selling clothes I'm in a business where
no one cares about anything except how
well your very last collection sold you
can't advertise for one group otherwise
you end up having a very small business
I want everyone I can get Jews Catholics
gays straights you name it action item
number three stay focused
entrepreneurs are easily distracted we
see other people launching successful
companies and it often raises doubts as
to whether your business will succeed or
not sometimes we just get bored with our
businesses I want to do something else
often before we've given enough time to
make sure our companies hit a critical
level of success the entrepreneurs who
achieve at the very highest levels stay
focused on their goals they don't allow
other opportunities to distract them and
to keep working on their businesses
until they reach what they set out to do
from a very early age client's goal was
to follow his passion for designing
clothes for every American every step
that he took along the way from
attending fashion school to taking low
paying internships to launching his own
business brought him closer to achieving
his goal everything else he ignored he
wanted to live his life with no regrets
and not be left wondering what would
have happened if he gave his very best
according to klein the money is not that
important to me whether it's 800 million
a billion or two billion
I think fantasies are for the birds
anything I wanted to do I did if there's
something I want nothing stops me
so remember be the expert reach a wide
audience and stay focused to finish up
this video I wanted to share one of my
favorite true stories about Calvin Klein
and some of his best quotes in his early
days when he was still working for other
designers Klein actually considered
putting the fashion industry all
together and going into the supermarket
business his friend Barry Schwartz had
just taken over his father's grocery
store in Harlem and had turned it into a
successful venture in his first six
months Klein was becoming increasingly
frustrated with his jobs and when
Schwartz offered him full partnership in
a supermarket it was hard to decline
fine at work at his own father's
supermarket for numerous years so he
knew what he was getting into what a
conversation over dinner one night with
his father would change Klein's life
forever he had gone to his parents asked
for advice expecting them to agree with
his decision to go into the supermarket
business with Schwartz instead Klein
says his father shocked him I think you
would be making a tremendous mistake he
said I don't understand what you've been
studying all these years but whatever it
is I don't think you've given it enough
of a chance Klein's father warned him
that if he didn't continue what he was
doing he would regret it for the rest of
his life
Klein stuck to his vision and stayed in
fashion
thank you for joining me for another
edition of all in the masters if you
like the video and want to see more
please give it a thumbs up I'd also love
to hear your thoughts and feedback if
you want to leave a comment below the
video and stay tuned for the next
episode